الى اخبار الساعه وزميلتي ميسون نوهه اليك
ميس شكرا لك رشا طبعا يعني كل هذا الحديث
اليوم عن هذه القمه واهميتها وطبعا ايضا
وضع سوريا سيكون اول ملف لدينا في اخبار
الساعه نبدا بالعناوين
القاده العرب يستعدون لقمه استثنائيه بجده
غدا الرئيس السوري يراس وفد بلاده فيها
رغم بيانات النصر من الدفاع الروسيه قائد
فاجنر يحذر القاده العسكريين الروس من
الانهيار
[موسيقى]
ادانات عربيه لاستفزازات اسرائيل في القدس
واشنطن تحذر من تاجيج التوتر وتدعو لضبط
النفس
وبعد تهم الفساد حاكم مصرف لبنان يقول
للعربيه انه متعاون مع القضاء ويعلن انه
باقي حتى نهايه ولايته
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا طبعا الملف الاول اليوم
في نشره اخبار الساعه هو من جده حيث يستعد
القاده العرب لانعقاد القمه الثانيه
والثلاثين وسط ظروف استثنائيه تمر بها
المنطقه العربيه وعلى راسها بالطبع الازمه
السوريه السودان ليبيا اليمن وفلسطين ووصل
الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد الى مدينه جده
للمشاركه في اعمال الدوره الثانيه
والثلاثين الاجتماع مجلس جامعه الدول
العربيه على مستوى القمه وكان الاسد اكد
انناقاد القمه العربيه في السعوديه سيعزز
العمل العربي المشترك لتحقيق تطلعات
الشعوب العربيه كما بدا صباح اليوم توافد
زعماء الدول العربيه الى جده للمشاركه
بهذه القمه
[موسيقى]
وقبل ذلك خاله معاون وزير الخارجيه
السوريه ايمن السوسان في مقابله مع
العربيه اجتها زميله رشا قال ان سوريا لم
تغب عن الجامعه العربيه بل ان التحديات
والظروف هي من فرضت بل فرضت عليها الغياب
عن الجامعه العربيه او عن العرب لتعود
اليهم سوريا حاره دائما وكلمات جميع من
الوفود العربيه بالامس تحدثت عن هذا
الحضور الدائم لسوريا في الوجدان العربيه
هناك ظروف
فرضت هذا الشيء ربما يكون علينا جميعا
اما العوده
لا اعتقد ان المصطلح هو صحيح المهم اليوم
نحن مع بعض هذا هو الوضع الطبيعي علينا
كعرب ان نكون مع بعض لان في ذلك الخلاص
لنا ما شهدته دولنا خلال 12 سنه الماضيه
يثبت هذا الشيء الشرور التي احاطت ببعض
الدول العربيه انعكست على الجميع وبالتالي
انعكست على الواقع العربي كان الواقع
العربي غير صار فاصبح واقعا ماسويا
[موسيقى]
عوده سوريا الى الجامعه العربيه بعد اكثر
من عقد على تجميد العضويه اعاد الى
الذاكره محطات تاريخيه خلال العقود
الثمانيه الماضيه منذ تاسيس الجامعه
بين اولى خطوات التاسيس لجامعه الدول
العربيه وعوده سوريا اليها بعد تجميد طويل
للعضويه ثمانيه عقود مرت فيها سوريا بتقلب
العلاقات مع الجامعه
تاريخيا سوريا كانت من اوائل الدول التي
شاركت بتمثيل قوي في الجامعه العربيه بعد
دعوه مصطفى النحاس رئيس الوزراء المصري
لنظيره السوري جميل مردنبك الى القاهره
لمناقشه انشاء تحالف عربي عام
1944 وتكون سوريا ضمن الدول السبع الموقعه
البروتوكول الاسكندريه
قمه الجامعه عام
1967 في الخرطوم وحربي يونيو حيث خسرت
سوريا مناطق ابرزها الجولان في الحرب مع
اسرائيل وسميت بقمه اللات ثلاث لا صلح لا
تفاوض ولا اعتراف باسرائيل شاركت فيها
كافه الدول العربيه باستثناء سوريا التي
دعت الى حرب تحرير شعبيه
بيان ختامي صدر عن القمه العربيه في
نوفمبر
1973 في الجزائر التي انعقدت بمبادره
سوريه مصريه يقضي بتقديم الدعم المالي
والعسكري لسوريا ومصر بعد شنهما حرب
اكتوبر على اسرائيل لاسترداد الاراضي التي
خسيرتها في حرب 1967
قمه مايو 1990 في بغداد غابت عنها سوريا
اثر الخلافات السياسيه بين دمشق وبغداد
لكنها عادت للحضور الى القمه الطارئه في
اغسطس من نفس العام في القاهره على خلفيه
غزو العراق للكويت لتدين الحرب وتتضامن مع
الدول الخليج في المطالبه باخراج القوات
العراقيه من الكويت
اما اخر القمم التي برز فيها اسم سوريا
كانت في نوفمبر 2011 بعد ان اجمع القاده
العرب على تجميد عضويه دمشق على خلفيه رد
فعلها على الحراك الشعبي في البلاد اذا
عمر العربيه
من دمشق ينضم الي الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
غسان يوسف استاذ غسان اهلا بكم معنا مدى
اهميه هذه القمه بالنسبه
لسوريا وكيف من الممكن ان تؤثر على حل
الازمه السوريه
تحيه
يعني هذه القمه طبعا هي قمه هامه لانها
يعني لاول مره تشارك سوريا بعد تجنيد قرار
العضويه في نوفمبر 2011 وايضا يعني هذه
القمه اليوم يعني كانت كل القمم العربيه
تعقد حول سوريا وتتخذ القرارات في رياضه
لكن اليوم هذه القمه يعني هي تنعقد بحضور
الرئيس بشار الاسد والذي سيكون له كلمه
وسيكون له موقف ويكون له لقاءات ثنائيه
ومن هنا كل القرارات التي ستصدر عن هذه
القناه ستكون قرارات هامه جدا بالنسبه
للوضع الداخلي السوري ولعلاقات كوريا مع
الدول العربيه وعلاقات كوريا مع يعني دول
العالم ما هي الاولويه استاذ غسان ساعود
الى نقطه اعاده علاقه سوريا مع العالم
ولكن ما هي اولويه سوريا اليوم بالنسبه
هذه القمه ماذا تريد سوريا من هذه القمه
ماذا ستطلب في هذه القمه
يعني طبعا
سوريا او الشعب السوري يعاني من وضع
اقتصادي الطعام يعاني من وجود ارهاب يعاني
من وجود تجاره مخدرات يعني عبر اراضيه
يعاني من عدم وجود
الالتزام بالمعاري الشرعيه ووصول
المساعدات الانسانيه الى المناطق الخارجه
عن سيجاره الدوله وعوده اللاجئين يعني كل
مواطن سوري يريد يعني نحن نشعر باهلنا
الذين يتكلمون
هل لديها اليه لعوده هؤلاء اللاجئين وهو
الملف الاهم حقيقه لانه ايضا يرهق دول
الجوار هل هناك اليه لعودتهم هل هناك
ضمانات لعدم التعرض لهم لانه يعني البعض
يخاف ان يعود بان يكون عليه اي يعني تقوم
سوريا بتوقيفه او
بمحاسبته على ما حصل خلال الاثني عشر عاما
كيف ستتعاطى سوريا في هذا الملف بالذات
انا اذكر يعني بالمقابله التي اجريت مع
معاون وجود الخارجيه اليوم على قناتكم
وايضا يعني هناك عوده للاجئين كما قلت الى
المكان الذي ولدته من جهه اخرى من اجل
يعني هناك مراسيم عفو صدرت عن الرئيس
الاسد وهناك مسار المصالحه يعني حتى الذي
حمل السلاح كان هناك مسار المصالحه معه من
قبل الدوله السوريه انا لا اعتقد اني كل
ما نسمعه ميكون يعني هذا هو تهويل
اوروبا كندا ضد عوده اللاجئين والانتصار
واللاجئين يعني بعض دول الزوار لم تكن
تريد ان يعود اللاجئون وايضا يعني هناك
قوى كالولايات المتحده والدول الاوروبيه
دائمه تتكلم بان هذه العوده ولكن انا اقول
لكن اريد ان اعلق على موضوع علاقه سوريا
مع دول العالم والان ذكرت الان الولايات
المتحده واوروبا هل ايضا من استراتيجيه
لعوده هذه العلاقه مع مع هذه الدول
انا اعتقد بان سوريا ليس لديها مانع من ان
يكون هناك علاقه مع الاتحاد الاوروبي
الولايات المتحده لكن
عن الشعب السوري
وعدم القول بان هذه العقوبات هي ضد النظام
وليس ضد الشعب هذا الكلام يعني لا
يقتنع به طفل صغير كل العقوبات التي
فرضتها الولايات المتحده اثرت علينا نحن
كشعب سوري ولاحظ انهيار الليره وايضا
ارتفاع الاسعار وكل هذا بسبب العقوبات
واعتقد بان سوريا منفتحه على اقامه اي
علاقه الدول العربيه من الممكن ان تساعد
سوريا على تحسين هذه العلاقه بايجاز
10 ثواني انا اعتقد ممكن يعني سمعنا
تصريحات للسعوديه والامارات والدول
العربيه اخرى لانها تطالب برفع قانون
باعاده العلاقات مع سوريا هذا وارد يعني
وحتى يعني دعوه الرئيس المشاركه في هذه
القمه وعوده سوريا اعتقد بان هذا موقف
عربي يحسب يعني لجامعه الدول العربيه
السعوديه باعتبارها هي الدوله المضيفه
شكرا لك الكاتب والمحل السياسي غسان يوسف
[موسيقى]
في اخبار الساعه سنتابع بعض لحظات تفاصيل
المخبا النوويه السريه الخاص بالرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
[موسيقى]
نتابع اخبار الساعه من الملف الاوكراني
وبالتحديد من باخ نوت حيث قالت نائبه وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني هان مليار ان روسيا تشن
هجوما في باخمت واضافت ان القوات
الاوكرانيه صدت الهجمات التي شنها الجيش
الروسي على مدى يوم كامل في المدينه
المحاصره مضيفه ان موسكو جمعت معظم قواتها
في اتجاه باخمت واستقدم التعزيزات بشكل
كبير
ورغم بيانات النصر من الدفاع الروسيه وجه
رئيس مجموعه باجنر العسكريه
رساله الى القاده العسكريين الروس حذر
فيها من انهيار الجبهه
[موسيقى]
لسوء الحظ تراجعت وحدات وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه لمسافه تصل الى 570 مترا شمال
بخموت مما كشف عن اجنحتنا انا اخاطب قياده
وزاره الدفاع علنا لان رسائل لا تقرا من
فضلك لا تتنازل عن الاجنحه افعل كل شيء
عليك حتى لا تنهار الاجنحه
سقف قدام الغربي لاوكرانيا ما فتح يرتفع
شيئا فشيئا فبعد الدبابات والصواريخ بعيده
المدى جاءت دور ربما على مقاتلات اف 16
الموضوع بات مطروحا بشكل علني بعد انشاء
حلفاء غربيين التحالفا دوليا لانجاز
الصفقه لكن تسليم المقاتل الامريكيه
الشهيره الى كيف يمر او لا عبر موافقه
واشنطن المتردده حتى الان صحيفه
ذكرت ان اداره بايدن وان تجاوزت العديد من
الخطوط الحمراء في مساعداتها الى كاذب الا
انها لا تزال تتمسك برفضها ارسال طائرات
مقاتله حديثه ويبدو بان القرار سيحسم في
الاسابيع الخليه القادمه وهو ما اعلن عنه
الامين العام لحلف الناتو يانس تولتنبر
والذي قال ان تسليم المقاتلات الغربيه
لاوكرانيا
سيناقش خلال اجتماع وزراء دفاع الناتو
الشهر المقبل
يقال مشاهدينا ان افضل طريقه للدفاع هي
الهجوم ويبدو انك بدات تتبع هذه الخطه
لقلب الطاوله على روسيا معطيات عديده تشير
الى ان القوات الاوكرانيه غيرت من
استراتيجيتها في الحرب وباتت تبادر
بالهجوم هذا ما اكدته صحيفه وولز التي
قالت في تقرير لها ان كيف انتقلت من مرحله
الدفاع الى الهجوم تقول الصحيفه ان
اوكرانيا باتت تشن هجمات تهدف الى تدمير
مخازن الذخيره ومخابئ الامدادات التي
تحتاجها القوات الروسيه وتراكات ان هذه
الهجمات النوعيه والدقيقه ستكون اكثر
فاعليه من مواجهه تقليديه امام القوات
الروسيه ما يفسر رغبتكاف في استهداف نقاط
اكثر عمقا هو طلبها المتزايد في الحصول
على مسيرات وصواريخ بعيده المدى من
الخلفاء الغربيين كما ترغب في انهاك
القوات الروسيه بانتظار وصول المزيد من
الاسلحه الغربيه لشن هجومها المضاد الكبير
يقوم العدو باستطلاع جوي يوميا ونحن
بالطبع نعمل لمحاوله اكتشافهم وتدمير
طائراتهم
عندما نبدا في التقدم تقوم القوات الروسيه
بقصف جميع الطرق المؤديه الى المواقع
الاماميه حتى لا تتمكن مركباتنا المدرعه
من ايصال المزيد من المشاه والذخيره
واشياء اخرى
مهمتنا هي عزل مركباتهم الجويه غير
الماهوله حتى لا يروا سوى القليل من
حركاتنا وافعالنا وعندما تصعب عليهم
رؤيتنا سيكون هذا امتيازا لنا
منضم الى الصحافه محمد البابا محمد اهلا
بك معنا هل يمكن ان تطلعنا على اخر
التطورات ان كان في العاصمه وين كانت في
الجبهات المشتعله منذ وقت طويل واهمها
بخمت
نعم بالفعل سابدا من باخموت حيث اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان الوحده 64 من
لواء المشاه الثالث قامت بهجوم على عدد من
مواقع القوات الروسيه مما ادى الى تراجع
القوات الروسيه حوالي 750 مترا بالطول
وحوالي يعني الفين متر بالعرض ومما ادى
الى تدمير اكثر من وتدمير واصابه وقتل
اكثر من 300 جندي روسي وهناك عدد يفوق ال
60 جندي روسي قد القوا السلاح واستسلموا
للقوات الاوكرانيه واصبحوا اسرى لدى الجيش
الاوكراني القوات الاوكرانيه ايضا قامت
اليوم بقصف عبر منظومات هيمرز ومنظومات
صاروخيه شديده حصلت عليها اوكرانيا خاصه
منظوره منظومه يعني صواريخ بريطانيه قامت
بقصف مخازن للاسلحه داخل مقاطعه
والثلاثه تجمعات قياديه للقوات الروسيه
بالقرب من باقي على بعد يعني 60 كم من
مدينه الجيش الاوكراني ايضا ينتشر بدا
بتبديل وحدات العسكريه من ماريانكا باتجاه
ضخمه من بخمت باتجاه ماريانكا تبديل لدعم
وتقويه صفوف القوات الاوكرانيه التي تقاتل
في منطقه ماريانكا وفي منطقه الجيش
الاوكراني بدا يعد للعده للهجوم وقال
الرئيس الاوكراني قبل حوالي ساعه من الان
في كلمته المسائيه انه اليوم كان هناك
اجتماع كبير لقياده الاركان الجيش
الاوكراني بحضور الرئيس الاوكراني ووزير
الدفاع الاوكراني ورئيس الوزراء وقاده
الالويه وقاده المخابرات الاوكرانيه
والاستخبارات العسكريه وربما يعني ما فهم
من هذا الاجتماع انه الاعداد او تحديد
الوقت لاو ساعه الصفر للهجوم المضاد خلال
الايام القليله الماضيه وقال الرئيس
الاوكراني ان اوكرانيا حصلت على جزء كبير
من الاسلحه التي كانت بحاجه اليها لتنفيذ
الهجوم المضاد
مثلا الى الاجتماع الذي سيعقد الاسبوع
المقبل
لتقرر دول حلف الناتو اذا كانت ستزود
اوكرانيا باب 16 ام لا
يعني هو لم يتكلم عن طائرات اف 16 ولكن
شكر القوات الجويه وقال ان اوكرانيا ستحصل
على مقاتلات لدعم الهجوم المضاد هذه يعني
هذا ما جاء في كلمه الرئيس الاوكراني
المسائيه ايضا الجيش الاوكراني اعلن رسميا
ايضا وبعد اعلان عن اعاده تصليح واعاده
يعني تشغيل منظومه التي تضررت جزئيا بفعل
الضربات الصاروخيه خلال اليومين الماضيين
بدات الان وعادت هذه المنظومه تعمل بشكل
طبيعي وهي لم تتوقف لان الجيش الاوكراني
الوضع مستتب فيها
نعم نعم كان هناك انذار جوي قبل حوالي
ساعتين ولكن لم يدم بسبب اقلاع طائرات ميج
31 تحمل صواريخ اقلعت وثم حطت في
بيلاروسيا لذلك توقف الانذار الجو الان
هناك ترقب لما سيحصل في الساعات القليله
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
ايضا مشاهدينا يبدو ان مساعي ايجاد حل
سلبي بين روسيا واوكرانيا تحول الى مجرد
سراب مع تمسك كل طرف مواقفه فشواهد تشير
الى ان اقناع الطرفين بالدخول في مفاوضات
السلام باتا بعيده المنال اخر هذه
الاشارات بالطبع زياره المبعوث الخاص
للصين الى كييف والذي التقى خلالها الرئيس
الاوكراني مبعوث اعترف بان الازمه لا يوجد
لها دواء سحري لتنتهي هو انه يتعين على
الاطراف تهيئه الظروف للمفاوضات كيف ترى
انفين لا تعد طرفا مناسبا للتوسط لانهاء
الحرب
خلال زيارته لاوكرانيا يلتقي الممثل الخاص
لي هو الرئيس الاوكراني فولودي اتفق
الجانبان على ان الاتصال الهاتفي بين
الرئيس شيجن بينج والرئيس الينسكي منذ وقت
ليس ببعيد اشار الى اتجاه تنميه العلاقات
الصينيه الاوكرانيه واتفق البلدان على
انهما يجب ان يعمل معا لمواصله تقليد
الاحترام المتبادل والصدق بين الجانبين
ومواصله دفع التعاون متبادل المنفعه بين
البلدين لا يوجد دواء سحري لحل الازمه يجب
على جميع الاطراف ان تبدا من نفسها وان
تتبادل الثقه وان تهيئ الظروف لانهاء
الحرب وبدء محادثات السلام على اساس
الوثيقه وموقف الصين من الحل السياسي
للازمه الاوكرانيه
هل تنجح مبادره السلام في ايقاف الحرب في
اوكرانيا
مساعي التوسط بين موسكو وكييف تصطدم بشروط
صارمه من الجانبين
فما هي الشروط كل طرف من اجل التفاوض
اوكرانيا لن نتنازل عن اي جزء من اراضينا
مقابل السلام
اي اتفاق سلام يجب ان يعتمد على احترام
سيادتنا ووحده اراضينا
روسيا يجب ايقاف امدادات الاسلحه الغربيه
لاوكرانيا يجب على كيافه تعهد بعدم
الانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي او الناتو
يجب حمايه حقوق المواطنين الناطقين
بالروسيه في اوكرانيا
الوساطه الصينيه حقيقه ليست الوحيده فهناك
مبادره افريقيه ايضا للمساعده في ايجاد حل
للنزاع بين ماسك موسكو وكيف المبادره تقود
هذه المره جنوب افريقيا التي قالت
في كل من موسكو
وتعد الدول الافريقيه من ضمن اكثر
المتضررين من النزاع ولا سيما في ارتفاع
اسعار الحبوب وسلاسل التوريد لكن ماذا عن
اصداء المبادره بالنسبه لثلاثاء رئيس جنوب
افريقيا سريل راما فوزا قال ان المبادره
لقيت دعما حذرا من الولايات المتحده وعدد
من العواصم الاوروبيه هذه المبادره تاتي
قبيل قمه روسيه افريقيه من المقرر عقدها
في نهايه يوليو المقبل من جانبه اكد
المتحدث باسم الكرملين
تساهم في حل الازمه الاوكرانيه
كانت هناك محادثه هاتفيه بين الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ورئيس جنوب افريقيا
وكانت محادثه جوهريه وبناءه رئيس جنوب
افريقيا قال باعتبار ان افريقيا اكبر قاره
تفكر ايضا اعطاء صوتها في الجهود الدوليه
لتسويه الوضع في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
كشف موقع انسايدر الاخباريه الامريكيه
تفاصيلها عن مخبا بوتين السري عقب اعاده
التفسير مخططات مقابل روسي نشرها على
موقعه الخاص للترويج لاعماله مقلع عام
20/10 مخططات بقيت متاحه على الانترنت حتى
اواخر عام 2016 نتابع
زعموا روسيا
وهو جالس يستعرض قدرات بلده النوويه يدرك
حد اليقين ان اي حرب تستعمل فيها هذه
الاسلحه ستكون مدمره قد تهدد وجوده شخصيا
على سطح الكوكب
مخبا سري لدى زعيم الكرملين يوجد تحت مجمع
فاخر يقع فوق منطقه منحدره تطل على البحر
الاسود المكان مخصص لمواجهه احتمال حدوث
حرب نوويه حسب موقع بيزنس
المجمع تبلغ مساحته 190 الف قدم مربع
وتكلفته مليار دولار يقع على منحدر واعر
يتمتع بكل رفاهيه يمكن ان يرغب فيها بوتين
المخبئ السري لبوتين اسفل مجمعه يتكون من
نفقين منفصلين يمكن الوصول اليهما عبر
مصعد كهربائي يهبط اكثر من 50 مترا تحت
السطح النفقان مغلقان بالاسمنت السميك
ومزودان بما يكفي من الماء العذب والتهويه
اللازمه ومقصورات واسعه لخدمه الشخصيات
المهمه لايام بل لاسابيع النفق السفلي
يؤدي الى ممر متحرك يقود الى الخارج يضم
كافه انواع الامن والسلامه النفقان مجهزان
بانظمه للحريق والمياه والمياه المجاري
كلها ترمي لكي يكون الشخص على قيد الحياه
او يتمكن من الهرب
الاستعداد للحرب النوويه بمخابئ محصنه لا
يخص بوتين فحسب بل لدى الزعماء في كل
الدول النوويه خطه الطوارئ القصوى في حال
اندلاع حرب مدمره بمن فيهما الرئيس
الامريكي الذي توجد مخابئه النوويه تحت
البيت الابيض وفي ولايه فيرجينيا بلال
الوجداني العربيه
[موسيقى]
شارك عشرات الالاف من الاسرائيليين في
مسيره الاعلام التي تنظم كل سنه في ذكرى
احتلال القدس الشرقيه وشارك وزير الامن
القومي اليمني اعتماد كبير ووزير الماليه
في المسيره وفي الوقت الذي توالت فيه
الادانات العربيه حذرت الرئاسه الفلسطينيه
من اصرار اسرائيل على تنظيم المسيره
الاستفزازيه من جانبها حتى الولايات
المتحده على الهدوء وضبط النفس بحسب مسؤول
في وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
في الاثناء اندلعت مواجهات بين فلسطينيين
واسرائيليين على هامش مسيره الاعلام في
المدينه فيما شنت القوات الاسرائيليه حمله
اعتقالات بحق فلسطينيين قالت انهم يخططون
للقيام باعمال عنف هذا وكثافه الشرطه
الاسرائيليه من تواجدها على طول خط سير
المسيره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في السودان كشفت المفوضيه الساميه للامم
المتحده للشؤون اللاجئين فرار اكثر من 113
الف شخص من القتال عبر الحدود مع مصر
وعودها مكتب المفوضيه في القاهره ان من
بين الفرلينا
107,286 سودانيه بالاضافه الى
5364 شخصا من جنسيات اخرى
لم يكن اعلانه الالتزامات وثيقه للهدنه
وجهه نظرنا انه تجب حمايه سبل المساعده
الانسانيه وتوزيعها مع او دون وقف اطلاق
النار هناك انتهاكات للاعلان منذ توقيع
الهدنه ومع ان الوثيقه تشير الى ضروره
حمايه المساعدات الانسانيه وعدم وقوع
هجمات على العاملين في المجال الانساني
الا ان هجمات وقعت على مكتب الغذاء
العالمي في الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
ابلغت الخارجيه السودانيه حكومه تجنب
السودان احتجاجها على زياره مستشار قائد
قوات الدعم السريع يوسف عزت الى جوبا
ونقلت وسائل اعلام سودانيه عن الوزاره
استغرابها لهذا التصرف الذي قام من خلاله
عزت بعقد اجتماع بحضور مسؤولين كبار من
حكومه جنوب السودان نفى على هامشه استخدام
الدعم السريع المواطنين كدروع بشريه
في اخبار الساعه نتابع بعد قليل
المسيرات الامريكيه تسيطر على اجواء
افغانستان
[موسيقى]
نتابع اخبار الساعه من لبنان حيث تحدث
حاكم مصرف لبنانيات سلامه عن التهم
الموجهه له وامكانيه اصدار حكم بحقه وقال
في مقابله مع العربيه انه سيتنحى عن منصبه
في حال صدور حكم ضده يثبت انه ارتكب ما
يتهم به
انا ضميري مرتاح وبعرف هالتهم مش مزبوطه
بعدين اذا ما كل واحد بده
يحتك بالحاكم ان كان انا وغيري بيعمل له
دعوه وهو بيقوم بيتنحى لكان وين استقلاليه
بنك المركزي وين السلطات اللي عنده اياها
بس يطلع علي حكم انه انا
مرتكب اكيد يعني بدي اتنحى بس اليوم على
تهم وتحقيقات وانا عارف انه شو فيه
بهالملفات كله
واوقات من الناس ما بعرفهم ولا الي علاقه
فيهم
بيعملوا دعابه
ففعلا اذا بده الحاكم يقطع لهالشيء يعني
كانه عم يستسلم لكل فريق عنده مصلحه انه
يخربط مصرف لبنان او متضايق من هالحاكم
بده يخلص منه
سلامه طالب ايضا بمحاكمه السياسيين في
لبنان بدلا من البدء بمحاكمته بصفته حاكم
لمصرف لبنان مؤكدا انه يبقى في منصبه بعد
انتهاء ولايته
يبلشوا يفرجونا عضلاتهم مع السياسيين
اعلنت من
اخر فصل 22
انه
هيدي اخر ولايه لالك حاكم للبنك المركزي
وانه هاي صفحه وطويتها وبعدني على الموقف
واللي مشغول باله بنرجع بنؤكد له انه مني
باقي النيه بالحاكم الاول في نوب عن
الحاكم اذا
بتسلم على الصلاحيات
[موسيقى]
والان اخبار الساعه سننتقل فيها الى الملف
الامريكي طريق الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب نحو البيت الابيض بالطبع هي
محفوفه بالمخاطر لكن ما يصعب المهمه هو
المواجهه امام الصديق الامس
فحاكم ولايه فلوريدا الجمهوري سيكون
منافسا لترانف على بطاقه الترشح عن الحزب
الجمهوري للانتخاباتي عشرين اربعه وعشرين
العديد من المصادر اشارت الى ان ديسانت
السيعلن ترشحه رسميا للانتخابات الرئاسه
الاسبوع المقبل وهذا الترشح من شانه ان
يثير حفيظه ترند في ظل شعبيه ديسانس
المتزايده وقدرته على جمع اموالا ضخمه
لدعم حملته الانتخابيه المنافسه طبعا
ستكون مشاهدينا ستكون على اشدها بين
الرجلين في ظل العلاقه القويه التي كانت
تربطهما قبل ان تنقلب الى
لم يتاخر في توجيه سهام الانتقاد
خصوصا مع اعتزامه الترشح بشكل رسمي واستغل
ترامب هزيمه الجمهوريين في مدينه جاكسون
فيل بولايه فلوريدا لمهاجمه ديسانتوس
وتحميله مسؤوليه تراجع هيمنه الجمهوريين
على الولايه وكتبت في منشور على منصته
ذاتروس سوشل ان سحر ديسانتس قد ذهب مضيفا
ان خساره مرشحه كانت خساره صادمه في
جاكسون
ولكن رغم صعود اسهم ديسانس في الحزب
الجمهوري بعد فوزه بولايه جديده على راس
فلوريدا نهايه السنه الماضيه غير ان شعبيه
الرجل قد تكون تراجعت نسبيا في الفتره
الاخيره وهو ما اشار اليه استطلاع للراء
الحديث كشف ان 61% من الاخبين المحتمدين
للحزب الجمهوري سيدعمون ترامب في انتخابات
20 24 مقابل 18%
من واشنطن تنضم الينا مديره مكتب العربيه
في واشنطن ناديه اهلا بك معنا الى اي حد
الطريق اصبح صعبا امام الرئيس ترامبا مع
ترشح ديسانتس كما هو متوقع في الاسبوع
المقبل
اهلا بك ميسون لا نستطيع ان نحكم الان
يعني اذا تحدثنا عن النسب كما ذكرتي لا
يزال الرئيس ترامب هو عراب الحزب الجمهوري
لا يزال يتربع على راس الهرم ومع ذلك
ديسانتوس يحظى بحوالي 18 الى 20% قبل ان
يترشح رسميا حسب معلومات العربيه هو انه
سيترشح الاسبوع القادم وربما على الارجح
ان يكون يوم الاربعاء بعد ذلك يمكن ان
نتحدث عندما يبدا المهرجانات الانتخابيه
عندما يبدا بجمع الاموال هل بالفعل سيكون
منافس حقيقي للرئيس ترامب حتى الان بدون
ادنى شك ترامب هو المتقدم لانه اعلن
الترشح قبل اي مرشح اخر ولديه اليه
لانتخابيه طبعا ولديه خبره يعني حتى خبره
في الحكم وخبره باداره الحملات الانتخابيه
لكن ترامب يعني يزعجه كثيرا
يعطيه القاب تحقره تقلل من قيمته الى اخره
ولا يفعل ذلك مع باقي المرشحين اذا هو
يعتبره المرشح الجد بالنسبه له وهو
ليستميل الجناح المحافظ في الحزب الجمهوري
الذي ربما لا يريد ترامب ان يكون مرشحا له
رغم القاعده الشعبيه المخلصه التي بقت مع
ترامب منذ اليوم الاول وحتى الان وهي
حوالي 30% من الحزب الجمهوري طب ناديه كما
سمعنا الرئيس ترامب يعني وضع في على
السوشيال ميديا يعني على التروث قال بانه
ديسانس هو المسؤول عن خساره الجمهوريين
هل هذا الامر ايضا من الممكن ان يؤثر على
شعبيه ديسانتوس وخاصه بانه ياتي من ترامب
ونحن نعلم كم هو جيد الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب بالتسويق
اكيد بدا يشحد السكاكين
لروندز ليس فقط في خساره الجمهوريه لهذا
المقعد في جاكسون فيلا لكن ايضا ربما
لاحقا لديه الكثير من الذخيره التي
سيستخدمها ضد حاكم ولاد فلوريدا لكن مقع
واحد لن يؤثر الان نحن نتحدث عن بدايه هذا
الصراع المحتدم والذي سيحكمه بالنهايه
الناخب الجمهوري في الانتخابات الاوليه
للحزب قبل عام من الانتخابات الرئاسيه
يعني انتخابات الرئاسيه تجري في نهايه عام
2024 ونحن نتحدث من الان عن هؤلاء
المرشحين وهجوم ترامب عليه وبالتالي يريد
ان يدمروا قبل ان يبدا هذه استراتيجيه على
كل حال المشاكل والتحديات ليست فقط امام
الرئيس ترامب وامام لسانتوس والجمهوريين
وانما ايضا امام الديمقراطين اسمح لي ان
تبقي معي ناديه لنتحدث اكثر عن التحديات
قبيل انتخابات 20 24 التي كما ذكرت ليست
حكرا على الجمهوريين فالرئيس جو بايدن
ايضا يواجه ازمات عده تؤثر على اسهمه اخر
هذه الازمات هي ازمه سقف الدين التي يمكن
ان تؤثر على حجم الانفاق العسكري وهي سلاح
ذو حدين فقد تكون بمثابه الورقه الرابحه
لبيدن اذا ما نجح في تجاوزها وفق مراقبين
متابع ومثما نعود الى ناديه
معركه التصريحات والاجراءات المضاده
تتواصل بين الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
والحزب الجمهوري قبيل موعد الانتخابات
الرئاسيه المقبله التي ستشكل حدا فاصلا في
مستقبل بايدن السياسيه رفع سقف الدين
العام يضم الى قائمه طويله من اسباب
الصراع الحاصل بين الرئيس الامريكي
والجمهوريين في مجلس النواب والذي سيحمل
معه تداعيات صعبه سترهق كاهل الاداره
الامريكيه الحاليه مع تحوله لاداه سياسيه
تعزز الانقسامات الايديولوجيه بين الحزبين
وتساهم بالدرجه الاولى في زعزعه مكانه
بايدن الذي لم يتمكن لحد الان من مواجهه
الازمات المتتاليه التي تمر بها البلاد
ابرزها جائحه كورونا وفق مراقبين بايدن
اليوم امام مازق سياسي معقد وضروره ايجاد
حل يرضي جميع الاطراف هو الحل الوحيد
لتدارك الموقف وكسب رهان التاييد الشعبي
خصوصا وان شعبيته تراجعت في الفتره
الاخيره غير ان هذا الحل مرتبط بالطرق
التي سيتم اعتمادها للتخفيف من الانفاق
ورفع سقف الدين طرق يتم بموجبها قبول
البيت الابيض بوضع حدود للانفاق الفيدرالي
وفرض قيود على الاعانات الاجتماعيه وهو ما
سيؤثر في سياق المتصل على حجم الانفاق
العسكري الامريكي وايضا تاثر العلاقات
الامريكيه الصينيه التي تعتبر فيها بيكين
اكبر دائن التشققات في هذه العلاقه ستتعمق
في حال التوقف عن سداد الديون الامريكيه
وستدفع الصين الى تعزيز موقعها في مجموعه
البريكس فضروره تمرير مشروع قانون يحظى
بتاييد الحزبين بات امرا ملحن وفق تصريحات
زعيم الاغلبيه المطلقه في مجلس الشيوخ
لتجنب خسائر فادحه ستواجهها اسواق المال
الامريكيه
والعالميه
اعود الى زميلتنا ناديه بلبيسي مديره مكتب
العربيه في واشنطن الى اي حد ناديه موضوع
ازمه سقف الدين اذا مات تجاوزها بايدن
ستساعده في الانتخابات بعد سنه
يعني من المبكر مره اخرى الحكم على هذا
الامر رغم انه في غايه الاهميه هناك
الكثير من المهارات السياسيه بين
الجمهورين وبين الديمقراطيين ونعرف
بالنهايه بان الرئيس بايدن هو رئيس مجلس
النواب سيتفقون على رفع السقف الدين العام
قبل حلول الموعد الطارئ وهو بدايه يونيو
لكن بدون ادنى شك سيكون هناك بعض
التاثيرات او التذبذبات السياسيه التي
ستؤثر على الطرفين لكن بشكل عام اعتقد بان
هناك مسلمات في موضوع سقف الدين منها
الانفاق العسكري يعني ميزانيه وزاره
الدفاع البينتاجون تتجاوز 700 مليار دولار
هذا لا يمكن المس به كذلك المشاريع الضمان
الصحي والضمان الاجتماعي ما يسمى
ميديكام للمتقدمين بالعمر هذا ايضا من
المسلمات اذا الاختلاف هو على هامش على
الانفاق الذي يقدمه المشاريع الدي التي
يقدمها الحزب والبيت الابيض وعلى الضرائب
التي تقوم يقوم الحزب الجمهوري بتخفيضها
دون ان يكون هناك مقابل للانفاق اذا اتوقع
بانه لن يؤثر كثيرا ولا هذا الطرف ولا ذلك
الطرف وكما تعرفين في الانتخابات
الامريكيه اسبوع واحد يمكن ان يقلب كل
الموازين لكن الموضوع بدون ان شكرا
تداعيات عالميه وليس فقط محليه امريكيه
شكرا لك من واشنطن مديره مكتب العربيه في
واشنطن
عاصفه الانسحاب الامريكي من افغانستان لم
تهدا بعد رغم مرور اكثر من سنه ونصف على
حدوثها فالتحقيقات لا تزال متواصله بشان
هذا الانسحاب الفوضوي وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه سمحت الاثنين من كبار اعضاء
مجلس النواب الاطلاع على نسخه منقحه من
برقيه سريه بشان عمليه الانسحاب في هذه
الاثناء لا تزال واشنطن مهتمه بوجودها في
افغانستان طبعا رغم الانسحاب والسبب
مواجهته الحركات الارهابيه حيث اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه استخدام جيل جديد
من الطائرات من دون الطيار لزياده رحلات
الاستطلاع فوق افغانستان فبهذه الخطوه
يطمح ان تنتجون لمواصله مراقبه الاراضي
الافغانيه لمواجهه طبعا اي تهديد ارهابي
لكن لماذا المسيرات السبب يعود لتجاوز قله
رحلات الاستطلاع الامريكيه في افغانستان
بسبب المسافه الطويله التي تتطلب التزود
في الوقت
ختاما نذكر بعناوين اخبار الساعه
القاده العربي يستعدون لقمه استثنائيه في
جده غدا والرئيس السوري الاسود بلاده
رغم بيانات النصر من الدفاع الروسيه قائد
يحضر القاده العسكريين الروس من الانهيار
وادانات عربيه لاستفزازات اسرائيل في
القدس و واشنطن تحذر من تاجيج التوتر
وتدعو لضبط النفس
بعد تهم الفساد حاكم مصرف لبنان يقول
للعربيه انهم متعاون مع القضاء ويعلن انه
باقن حتى نهايه
ولايته
اشكر لكم طيب المتابعه اترككم في امان
الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات